et en démon qui s'est manifestée de
mémoire
notre enquête de ce soir à commencer par
des morts par l'uimm bertrand mais on
l'a découvert que derrière ces faits
divers il y à une boisson hallucinogènes
préparer en amazonie qui fait de plus en
plus d'adeptes dans le monde notamment
chez des vedettes de santé comme si
quelque chose vous voyagez à travers
toutes les cellules de mon corps comme
une intelligence qu'il cherche partout
une expérience qui n'est pas sans danger
une puissance lumineuse on met elle
aussi mener vers les 2 ème rang
26 des livres on peut avoir un tertre
contact avec la réalité
plusieurs touristes dont une canadienne
sont morts alors qu'ils participaient à
des cérémonies chamanique en amérique du
sud est deux fois et les revenus
inchangé la troisième fois et demie
parvenu est au coeur de ce rituel une
passion hallucinogènes qu'on appelle
ayahuasca laplante a fait sortir quand
vous prenez le sacrement votre
conscience s'élève ce soir johan fauché
à l'aiea belle et nos collègues la cible
ici nous emmène dans un voyage mystique
et inquiétant
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
avril 2018
le village de villa gracia au pérou
devient une scène de crime
attention ces images sont difficiles à
regarder cette vidéo a fait le tour du
monde
un canadien se fait lyncher par des
indigènes qui l'accusent d'avoir tué
leur chaman nous apprenons qu'il aurait
connu une fin atroce pour de l'ayahuasca
cette histoire choquante nous a
intrigués
elle nous a mis sur la piste d'une
drogue puissante
nous avons découvert un univers
insoupçonné
d'abord l'ayahuasca est une boisson
hallucinogènes utilisée depuis des
millénaires par des chamans en amazonie
depuis une vingtaine d'années il y à un
engouement pour cette boisson chamanique
entre autres chez des vedettes comme le
chanteur anglais sting chiots des
contreurs france maroc existe
l'écrivaine belge amélie nothomb homme
s'est rendu dans ce centre au milieu de
la jungle pour régler son problème
d'estimé de soi
aya waska took me and told me that love
child and give me that should he loves
takes 9eme genoa existe
[Musique]
à
plus près de nous le chanteur yann
perreau a composé une valse à l'iowa ce
cas moi j'ai eu la chance de goûter avec
une gang dans la ville dans une maison
où tout le monde chantait des chansons
tout le monde était telle pour guérir
des trucs tout ce que j'ai fait c'est
une journée psy avait des gens tous les
argiles des docteurs des avocats des
victimes
vraiment du monde jeunesse de
l'ayahuasca est interdite dans la
majorité des pays occidentaux
malgré tout des cérémonies clandestine
se tiennent un peu partout nous nous
rendons à longue haleine une banlieue de
new york
nous assisterons à une cérémonie
d'ayahuasca bioen l'île de man est un
ancien héroïnomane lors d'un séjour en
prison
il entend parler des présumés vertu de
l'ayahuasca pour régler des problèmes de
dépendances
à sa sortie il a tenté l'expérience
aujourd'hui bio on se dit chaman et
organise des cérémonies d'ayahuasca
presque toutes les semaines chez lui il
sait très bien que c'est illégal mais il
est prêt à prendre le risque
[Musique]
des photos avec son apprenti le chaman
américain prépare la boisson
hallucinogènes qui sera servi ce soir
plus mais ne veut tenir au ricoh
quelqu'un des sources politiques
[Musique]
il est 21h cinq personnes participeront
à la cérémonie à l'intérieur pendant ce
temps une chamane de colombie dirige un
autre groupe dans la cour arrière
il s'agit pour la plupart de leurs
premières pratiques d'ayahuasca les ont
payés 150 $ chacun deux doses leur
seront servis au cours de la nuit
la boisson un goût amer un des
participants est pris de vomissements
c'est normal c'est ce qu'on appelle la
purge
elle peut être très violent
les gens s'étendent emmitouflés dans des
couvertures pour accueillir les visions
au bout de 30 minutes les effets
commencent la cérémonie durera 12 heures
l'expérience est différente pour chacun
selon les adeptes la plancha manic et
doté d'un esprit qui apparaît sous la
forme d'animaux est souvent sous les
contours d'une jeune femme
un voyage intérieur ou de vieux
souvenirs remontent à la surface pour
certains réveiller de vieux démons peut
s'avérer troublant fabriquer des lic
c'est une substance qui produit des
hallucinations en général ça dure assez
longtemps aussi c'est pas le genre de
substance à prendre seul parce qu'on
peut avoir une petite perte de contact
avec la réalité des parents division des
expériences de déconnexion avec le corps
ou même d'introspection en profondeur
dans l'inconscient pour jean sébastien
fallu spécialiste en toxicomanie ouvrir
les portes de l'inconscient est toujours
risqué chez des gens qui ont refoulé des
choses dans leur passé par mécanisme de
défense des agressions sexuelles et des
abus
physique qu'ils ont subi toutes sortes
de traumatismes des deuils là
l'expérience d'introspection peut les
mettre en contact avec 60 soit
nécessairement préparés
une recherche sur facebook avec les
mots-clefs ayahuasca et montréal nous
mène à ce groupe de 330 membres
nous ne donnons pas d'informations sur
les cérémonies d'ayahuasca à montréal
puisque c'est malheureusement illégal si
vous souhaitez vraiment faire
l'expérience de l'ayahuasca
n'abandonnait pas vos recherches vous
n'avez pas à vous rendre au pérou
le remède est bien présent à montréal et
partout au monde
nous avons voulu savoir où se tiennent
les cérémonies d'ayahuasca et qui les
organisent nous avons d'abord assisté à
une séance de guérison chamanique où
l'on sert une boisson à base de cacao
nous avons demandé à l'animatrice si
elle organise également des cérémonies
d'ayahuasca katiri affinait nous
confirme par courriel je travaille avec
un chaman depuis quelques années qui
vient à montréal pour des cérémonies
d'ayahuasca deux fois par année mais et
novembre jointe au téléphone
elle affirme que plus de 80 personnes se
sont inscrites à la cérémonie de
novembre
connaissez vous des gens qui organisent
des cérémonies et montréal au moins une
quinzaine de personnes
oui mais c'est que c'est illégal au
canada est ce que ça vous pose un
problème
non pas du tout non le fait une plante
sacrée conclu ça n'a rien à voir avec la
loi suisse et au delà les contraintes du
monde matériel
elle refuse notre demande d'entrevue
craignant tout de même des ennuis avec
la justice
[Applaudissements]
rebecca et d'une donne des conférences
et à nîmes à partir de toronto
aya waska topps une émission de radio
diffusée sur le web sont invités par le
gouvernement des cérémonies qu'elle
organise ici au canada
basta ils n'ont en fait date
jointe au téléphone marilou crème
maintenant la justice et refusent notre
demande d'entrevue l'ayahuasca étant
illégale au canada
personne ne nous permet de filmer une
cérémonie
nous nous sommes rendus au pérou pour en
apprendre davantage dans ce pays
ce remède ancestrales et légal est au
coeur d'un commerce florissant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'ayahuasca est préparée selon le rituel
chamanique des tribus amazoniennes
lavigne ayahuasca est considérée comme
une plante sacrée au pérou elle est
mélangée à l'affût de chaque rona qui
contient le dmt impuissante
hallucinogènes ensemble elles sont bulli
pendant plusieurs heures
résultat une boisson brune épaisse au
goût très amer
ce qui ne semble pas décourager des
adeptes depuis une vingtaine d'années le
tourisme centré sur l'ayahuasca s'est
développé de façon exponentielle des
milliers de touristes affluent chaque
année vers la mecque de l'ayahuasca
epito ce un phénomène de mode
une expérience mystique un traitement
médical chacun a ses raisons de faire le
voyage
j'aurais pu le faire en suède mais je
voulais aller à la source
j'ai choisi de venir à iquitos isabelle
taux relais a été agressée sexuellement
à l'âge de 14 ans elle espère que
l'ayahuasca va l'aider à panser ses
blessures
je souffre du syndrome de stress post
traumatique de douleurs chroniques
j'étais toxicomane j'ai pris des
médicaments vu des médecins eu des
chirurgies rien ne m'a aidé
j'espère vraiment l'ayahuasca va régler
mais trop mince
dans ce café des kits os l'esprit de
l'ayahuasca s'affiche sur les murs
tellerie d'ottawa est arrivé il ya deux
jours à la croisée des chemins dans sa
vie professionnelle elle vient demander
à la plante sacrée de l'aider à faire
des choix
maintenant je sais pas où je veux aller
après juste il ya trop d'options fait
cette décision me fait tellement
m
[Musique]
et je veux juste ou des options puisque
a moqué de lui que je veux je veux à
l'expérience et quelque chose un petit
peut-être pas mais les naviguer seuls
des dizaines de retraite dispersés dans
la jungle
accueil des touristes pour cent dollars
américains par jour
laplante a fait sortir tout mène toute
la rage toutes les émotions les émotions
négatives qui sont accumulés au long de
la vie et tout ça ces manifestions sous
forme de démo en fait et c'était
vraiment un exorcisme ya pas diego
basters du luxembourg vient de passer
dix jours dans une retraite d'ayahuasca
l'expérience a été révélatrice
mais difficile tout à coup il ya un
diable ou un démon si on veut qui s'est
manifesté devant mois d'avril et il
avait une couleur noir satin comme ça
c'était c'est très bizarre sont rappelés
après quand on revient mais je sais que
je sais encore c'est ce que c'est que
j'avais très peur et que j'avais les pas
l'impression c'était une hallucination
du tout si tu viens pour faire un trip a
alors mangent les champignons prendre
les laisser si tu veux vraiment faire un
trip pour triper mais si tu veux faire
ça pour le fun
non c'est pas de la rigolade c'est
vraiment pas la vega la halle au marché
belem à iquitos jenny torres vend toutes
sortes de plantes médicinales
l'ayahuasca c'est la corde de l'âme de
l'esprit on l'appelle aussi la mer à
yamaska et 1 et massagno c'est nettement
plus la vigne vieille plus l'énergie est
positive pendant les visions jenny nous
amène dans son entrepôt on prépare une
commande pour un centre de guérison
voici mon ami codé cody est un client
américain qui travaille dans un des
centres de yamaska jenny en
approvisionne plusieurs autour des kits
hausse mais elles vont aussi à
l'étranger
nous exportons ce remède vers plusieurs
pays comme l'inde la russie la hollande
mais principaux acheteurs sont des
hollandais et des américains jenny
torres n'est pas la seule à faire de
bonnes affaires de commerce autour de
l'ayahuasca est florissant ce qui amène
son lot de problèmes des locaux mal
intentionnés en profite pour se faire
passer pour des chamans on parle de
villageois qui gagnent en moyenne 200
dollars par mois
maintenant ils peuvent faire mille
dollars en une nuit
même s'ils ne savent pas utiliser les
plantes médicinales de façon sécuritaire
c'est un incitatif au pérou depuis six
ans l'américain qui se fait appeler
daniel love s'apprête à ouvrir son
centre d'ayahuasca il critique le
commerce autour de la pratique
chamanique les gens qui organisent des
cérémonies doivent réfléchir à leur
comportement ils sont responsables de
vies humaines dame qui sont sacrées et
précieuse personnellement je n'ai pas
encore rencontré un chaman en qui j'ai
totalement confiance
l'expérience de l'ayahuasca n'est pas
sans risque on rapporte des cas
d'agressions sexuelles les vols et même
des décès au moins une dizaine de
touristes de partout dans le monde sont
morts depuis une dizaine d'années lors
de cérémonies au pérou parmi ceux ci la
canadienne jennifer login 32 ans morte
en 2015
les circonstances sont nébuleuses les
chamans ajoute parfois d'autres plantes
et d'autres remèdes ancestraux lors des
cérémonies difficile de déterminer ce
qui a tué ces touristes c'est impossible
à prédire comment les gens vont réagir à
une substance hallucinogène
lajos cas est contre indiqué pour les
gens souffrant de schizophrénie ou de
bipolarité
pour le psychiatre le rancoule ou dont
la boisson amazonienne n'est pas pour
tout le monde de façon générale les gens
qui ont déjà fait des psychoses qui ont
des fragilités à faire des psychoses sur
les substances devrait éviter cette
substance le et les gens qui prennent
des antidépresseurs aussi devrait éviter
cette substance le à ce moment là on a
des complications physiques qui peuvent
mener jusqu'à la mort
après la pause des voyages enquête
d'ayahuasca se termine dans un bain de
sang
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
perou 16 décembre 2015
dans cette cuisine du centre phénix
ayahuasca un canadien tué un britannique
des deux coups de couteau je ne voulais
pas ça je l'aimais vraiment je pensais
que nous serions amis pour longtemps
[Musique]
interview et deux jours après le drame
joshua stevens 29 ans est sous le choc
il explique avoir agi en légitime
défense c'est ici qu'il m'a mordu il ya
une autre blessure là je crois c'est une
coupure de couteau une éraflure il m'a
taillader le doigt il ne me lâchait pas
c'était lui ouvre
nous avons retrouvé jeu choix chez lui à
winnipeg
j'ai grandi dans un quartier pauvre où
il y avait beaucoup de drogue de
gagneuse on ne peut pas être plus accros
que je l'étais il est convaincu que
l'ayahuasca la sauver mais ça m'a aidé à
me débarrasser de mes dépendances à
l'alcool la cocaïne au sexe à la
nourriture à la pornographie
toutes ces choses négatives qui m'ont
fait du mal
ça m'a aidé à m'en sortir la boisson
chamanique l'aurait également guéris
d'autres maladies j'avais des éruptions
cutanées aux deux bras j'ai vu plusieurs
médecins et aucun ne savait quoi faire
les rougeurs ont disparu le lendemain
c'est grâce à la grèce qu'à son poursuit
[Musique]
sa démarche thérapeutique l'amène au fin
fond de la jungle en décembre 2015
c'est là qu'il rencontre une aide gomes
un jeune britannique
il avait des idées et des rêves pour
changer le monde
le rendre meilleur il était intelligent
dans la nuit du 15 décembre je choix se
prépare à boire de l'oeil à wasquehal
seul dans sa chambre
pas très loin dans une hutte unesco mais
ce bois une dose d'ayahuasca puis quitte
le groupe en criant il m'a saisi et a
mis son bras autour de mon cou une prise
ferme qui pouvait sembler amical mais
quelque chose n'allait pas il m'a dit
que c'était le temps de faire sortir
mais dément ok même avec l'aide de deux
gardiens je sois n'arrive pas à
maîtriser une haïssent ils semblent
avoir une force herculéenne
les hommes se battent corps à corps
pendant de longues minutes une aise
s'empare d'un couteau
ça devient sérieux quand il a saisi un
couteau
j'étais terrifiée au bout d'un moment je
sois parvient à lui arracher le couteau
et le tourner contre son adversaire
je les poignarder à l'estomac
ici il cherchait encore à prendre le
couteau il était toujours agressif il ne
me lâchait pas gelé poignardé une
deuxième fois un coup fatal celui
[Musique]
rejoints au centre phénix ayahuasca où
la tragédie a eu lieu un témoin qui a
participé à la bagarre corroborent la
version du jeune canadien
[Musique]
je ne sais pas si on peut appeler ça de
la légitime défense
mais ce n'était pas intentionnel c'est
arrivé pendant la bagarre
il voulait juste lui enlever les
couteaux j'ai déjà vu ce genre de choses
les gens sur la jsk qui semblait
posséder et qui se mettaient à mordre à
donner des coups de pied et des coups de
poing ce qui vient d'arriver
c'est le plus extrême que j'ai jamais vu
on peut rentrer en psychose avec pas mal
de substances bien en particulier avec
les substances hallucinogènes des
substances comme celle là peuvent
effectivement entraîner des problèmes
psychotiques passagers ou plus permanent
chez des personnes qui seraient
notamment vulnérables vingt-quatre
heures après le drame
je choix sera libérée à ce moment-là il
affirme que malgré tout il reprendra
doha ce cas on sort je n'arrêterai pas
pour autant c'est un remède puissant
je n'arrive pas vraiment à expliquer ce
qui s'est passé mais je sais ce dont
l'ayahuasca est capable
hélas une puissance lumineuse mais elle
peut aussi mener vers les ténébreuses si
quelqu'un qui n'a pas d'expérience
communiste bois tout une tasse les
portes des ténèbres peuvent s'ouvrir
sébastien audois a lui aussi connu le
côté sombre de l'alaska
c'est lui qui a été lynché par des
péruviens le printemps dernier
j'ai 37 ans et je suis le père d'un
charmant garçon de 4 ans et demi
les mésaventures de sebastian commence
avec cette vidéo publiée il ya cinq ans
et la masse des fonds pour aller étudier
les vertus de l'iowa ce cas au pérou
j'ai décidé de lâcher ce que je faisais
changer de carrière pour devenir un
conseiller en dépendance son père guéri
vaudois l'encouragent mis son grand ami
qui s'intéresse aussi aux plantes
médicinales crois que sébastien est
aussi allé au pérou pour lui même la
première fois qu'il est allé au pire où
je n'étais pas inquiet j'ai pensé super
fait ce voyage et reviens tu aura
probablement une meilleure connaissance
de soi même
sébastien a d'abord expérimenté
l'ayahuasca en colombie britannique
puis il a fait trois voyages au pérou en
quatre ans il se rendait à puch hype à
l'un des centres touristiques de
l'ayahuasca mais il parlait peu de ce
qu'il faisait là bas il était de plus en
plus distant et monrose lorsqu'il
revenait et voyage du retour je pense
qu'il a surchargé son système nerveux
avec les années il avait changé
c'était difficile de communiquer avec
lui je suis un peu seul c'est ainsi
j'aimerais avoir des copains avec qui me
tenir quelqu'un pourrait me voir ça ne
va pas je parle pour la jungle à la
recherche de mon âme et pour réparer mon
esprit on se reverra canche ribéry sa
famille ne le reverra jamais lors de son
dernier voyage au pérou sebastian se
rend dans le village de victoria gracia
c'est ici que vivait la chamane olivia
arevalo
et l'été notre grammaire une aide
spirituelle
on ne sait pas ce que sébastien goulet
il insistait pour faire de l'ayahuasca
avec elle mais elle n'en prenaient pas
elle n'en avait pas besoin
il se rendait chez le matin l'après midi
le soir la nuit à toute heure du jour
ce n'était pas une personne normale
au cours des derniers mois sébastien
avait un comportement de plus en plus
étranges les villageois raconte que le
canadien n'est menacée avec un bâton il
avait peur de lui
le 3 avril sébastien achète de ce
policier un pistolet taurus 9 mm pour 3
mai sol l'équivalent de 1200 dollars
canadiens deux jours plus tard il écrit
sur facebook c'est difficile je passe un
mauvais quart d'heure
s'il vous plaît envoyez moi vos prières
le 19 avril en matinée sebastian quête
en moto pour kai part il se rend encore
une fois chez la chamane olivia arevalo
les deux se disputent la pression elle
complique temps est la pression les
conflits il y a eu des crises il a
pointé son arme et tiré deux coups
jeunesse parade aux terrasses
après enquête le procureur carlos vicat
wegmann est convaincu que sébastien est
l'auteur du meurtre
quels lots 100 milliards ligne spo
l'adresse les proches d'olivier et des
villageois l'ont encerclé l'ont attrapé
et c'est là que c'est arrivé elle a 70
younes à cesson - la police a retrouvé
le corps de sebastian wood oif
les villageois l'avait enterré pas très
loin de la maison lors de la
perquisition de la chambre de ses basten
la police ne trouve rien d'anormal
il ya pourtant sur cette table un indice
important des médicaments des cachets
prescrit six mois plus tôt au canada de
clonazépam et de la nappe in des
médicaments qui laisse croire qu'elle
aurait été diagnostiquée bipolaire ou
schizophrène si vous avez un trouble
bipolaire vous êtes plus à risque de
vivre une expérience déstabilisante soul
influence de l'ayahuasca le professeur
en psychiatrie charles bob est connu
internationalement dans le domaine des
drogues psychédéliques
il n'a pas vu le dossier médical de
sebastian wood oif
mais selon lui il aurait dû se tenir
loin de la yamaska thousand d'or mais ce
procès cette personne a peut être cru
que des gens autour d'elle représentait
une menace
en réalité ce n'était pas le cas
c'était une exagération de son esprit
déclenchée par un état psychiatrique
[Musique]
la police a promis une récompense de 20
mais le sol soit 8000 dollars canadiens
pour retrouver des suspects you aucun
encore été accusé dans cette histoire
sanader
paris
s'pace games
c'est illégal de se procurer de
l'ayahuasca au canada sauf si on fait
partie de certaines organisations
religieuses et on vous explique pourquoi
tu dans un instant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis le 5 juin 2017 l'ayahuasca et
consommer en toute légalité par deux
églises du québec dont celle de montréal
qui compte une trentaine de membres sur
menchov crush crush 9 la conscience du
christ se manifeste en nous et c'est la
lumière divine de santo daime qui
éveille en nous la seconde venue du
christ la fondatrice jessica ward
chester explique que l'ayahuasca qu'elle
appelle santo daime est utilisé comme
sacrement à l'image de l'eucharistie
chez des catholiques pour nous et la
cuma azzurri 2 lorsque nous buvons le
sacrement
cela nous permet de voir le meilleur de
nous mêmes nos forces notre bonté
la connexion avec le meilleur de soi
mais ça révèle ou si le pire de nous
mêmes les membres de ces idiots montréal
ont accepté d'être filmée lors d'une
pratique de champ mais ils nous ont
interdit leur cérémonie religieuse et
nous sont référés à ces images tournées
au brésil en nous disant qu'ils ont le
même cérémonial la religion saint-aubin
mais a été fondée en 1930 au brésil par
un descendant d'esclaves africains en
jessica watch et ste est revenue
d'amérique du sud avec une mission la
mission était d'implanter la religion
santo daime ici au canada en toute
légalité
elle demande à santé canada
l'autorisation d'importer et de servir
de l'ayahuasca sur la base de la liberté
religieuse
les documents obtenus par l'accès à
l'information démontrent que santé
canada a longuement étudié la question
après avoir consulté l'organe
international de contrôle des
stupéfiants des nations unies les
autorités brésiliennes
différents experts en drogue et la grc
qui affirment qu'il n'y a pas de marché
noir
santé canada conclut que la consommation
d'ayahuasca dans un cadre religieux ne
représentent pas de risques d'autant
plus que cette drogue psychoactives ne
créerait pas de dépendance
jessica rochester attendu 16 ans avant
d'obtenir le feu vert au total trois
groupes religieux ont obtenu une
dérogation de santé canada et deux
autres demandes sont présentement à
l'étude la dose maintenant que la porte
est ouverte
croyez vous que tout le monde peut
obtenir une dérogation en croire non
tout le monde peut la demander
je pense que santé canada est capable de
discerner les gens sérieux de ceux qui
ne sont pas au front de la consommation
d'ayahuasca reste interdite pour des
cérémonies chamanique éric beaulieu
allait l'apprendre à ses dépens après
avoir fait l'expérience de l'ayahuasca
en equateur il a voulu en refaire au
canada jeunes à montréal
dans cet élan de mieux-être avec et
j'avais le goût de partager avec
d'autres personnes cette expérience là
que j'avais eu cette remarque invite à
traverser ça sur le site facebook
aya waska col inédit il trouve
l'annoncent d'une chaman qui propose de
tenir une cérémonie à montréal il
accepte de participer à l'organisation
et que l'ayahuasca soient livrés chez
lui le pire scénario possible selon lui
c'est que la marchandise soit confisquée
aux douanes aucun cas d'arrestation ou
même d'amande n'a été rapporté il espère
que les bouteilles passeront la
frontière avec l'aide de mer ayahuasca
début janvier
j'en reçois un courriel on envoie le
paquet avec le système de livraison dhl
on va donner le numéro de suivi tout ça
fait qu'on me l'envoie le paquet il
reste pris 3 4 jours à miami
c'est normal bon une autre surprise
l'attend reçoit un coup de téléphone de
douanes canada qui faisait bon on a un
paquet pour vous alors
on sent que ça vient du pérou soit clair
sur l'étiquette qu'est ce que c'est
pouvez-vous nous guider parce que on
peut pas libérer le colis temps qu'on
s'est passé quoi faites moi je respire
deux coups j'ai envie de donner moins
peu plus d'infos sur le paquet et puis à
parle plus dans ma tête ça fait avorter
la sphère file anti finalement laissé
faire je replace pas ce paquet l'a
laissé tomber avec le lendemain matin je
regarde sur internet
pâques est en cours de livraison avec le
chef ops
ok ça sonnait à porte c'est un gars
brillant dhl qui avec l'étiquette dhl
tout ça livreur en bonne et due forme et
je prends le paquet j'appelle tout de
suite la fille au pérou pour lui sur le
fait qu'elle rentrait du manque
seulement ok mais ça dans le frigo
je sens un frigo tout de suite après ça
cogne à la porte bang bang bang
j'ouvre la porte on met par terre un
fusil devant rester à l'us 9th inde
c'est j'étais tétanisé le l'intervention
policière était lancée dehors la rue est
bouclée
cet agent de la grc et du spvm folle son
condo éric beaulieu collaborent et leur
dit que ce qu'il cherche
et dans le réfrigérateur est descendu
avec les menottes
là je voyais l'ampleur de l'opération
kéré eu lieu c'est comme els chaffaut
sait quoi faire
sap a devancé
le moral est accusé d'importation de dmt
sous forme d'ayahuasca complot pour
importation et possession
il est passible de 10 ans de prison je
présume qu'ils pensaient que j'étais un
maillon d'une chaîne quelconque ce qui
était pas mon coach était initiative
totalement personnelle un maillon de
maillon d'une chaîne de trafic de risque
au québec je sais pas je présume
c'est seulement des mois plus tard qu'il
comprend ce qui s'est vraiment passé
qu'est ce qui est arrivé c'est là qu'on
comprend la démesure de l'opération la
police allemande avait déjà reçu des
paquets du pirou du même compte
dhl qui a livré mon pas que chez moi la
police allemande surveillaient un
certain quand d'expédition dhl quand le
paquet est parti du pérou pour miami
elle a prévenu le fbi
le fbi a immédiatement avisé la grc que
l'adresse du destinataire était à
montréal sa dernière qui l'a construite
en national ce gars c'est comme un film
jamais pu vivre intensément ce qui
commence par une opération policière
d'envergure se dégonfle devant les
tribunaux le procureur reconnaît qu éric
beaulieu ne voulais pas en faire le
trafic
lyon qui avait dit de nous fatiguer le
du boulot a expliqué une explication
approbation que montant d'argent pour
éric beaulieu plaide coupable la
possession simple il reçoit une
absolution inconditionnelle et n'aura
pas de dossier criminel
cette mésaventure lui aura coûté 20 mai
dollars en frais d'avocats
après la pause on vous parle de gens
très sérieux qui veulent légaliser
l'ayahuasca en 2011 l'émission donné
tube d'inxs de siby ci faisait état des
démarches du médecin de vancouver gabor
mater pour utiliser l'ayahuasca pour
traiter ces patients toxicomanes
documenter à la suite de ce reportage le
docteur matt et reçoit un avertissement
de santé canada qui lui ordonne de
cesser immédiatement les traitements
avec l'ayahuasca sans quoi elle
préviendra la grc
il a cessé de l'utiliser au canada mais
et s'en sert toujours en amérique du sud
là où la boisson est légal mais au
canada
l'intérêt pour l'ayahuasca n'est pas
disparu si vous êtes un professionnel en
santé mentale je vous encourage à
propager cette nouvelle approche auprès
de vos collègues 250 chercheurs et
professionnels de la santé se sont
réunis à victoria cet automne lors d'un
forum sur les psychédéliques
plusieurs croient que les substances
comme le lsd les champignons magiques et
l'ayahuasca pourrait aider à traiter des
gens souffrant de dépression et de
dépendance aux drogues
nous essayons de nous mettre au travail
avec d'autres équipes de recherche en
europe et aux états unis qui examine
l'efficacité médicale de ces substances
pour traiter la dépression l'anxiété la
dépendance le syndrome de stress
post-traumatique ou les troubles
alimentaires des types de maladies pour
lesquelles la médecine occidentale offre
peut-être pas le meilleur traitement
quant à l'iowa ce cas plusieurs livres
ont été écrits sur le sujet mais il n'y
a eu aucune étude clinique ni aux
etats-unis au canada au laser le mettais
américain joseph schaefer n'attend pas
la légalisation
il travaille comme médecin consultant
pour un centre qu'il a cofondé au pérou
entre une famille selon moi quand il
s'agit de traiter des maladies aux
racines émotionnel ce qui n'intéresse
pas la médecine occidentale
il faut rechercher ce qui est au coeur
d'un trauma ce qui perturbe de l'esprit
et le corps les wascat peut nous révéler
sa ces chercheurs et médecins demandent
au gouvernement fédéral d'investir et de
faciliter les recherches
habituellement c'est l'industrie
pharmaceutique qui finance la recherche
médicale
elle n'a démontré aucun intérêt pour
cette classe de médicaments
peut-être en grande partie parce qu'il
n'est pas possible de les brevetés et
que ce ne serait pas rentable comme en
1960 lippi et le lsd les adeptes voit
dans la consommation d'ailleurs à ce
qu'à une forme d'émancipation incomprise
par une société conservatrice
les chemins nous avaient expliqué qu'ils
avaient une légende qui était très forte
dans leur culture qui par l'idée que
quand l'aigle va rencontrer le condor le
symbole de l'aig c'est l'amérique du
nord qu'on dort jamais une seule
il va falloir que la plante se propage
potion magique
les adeptes en sont convaincus mais elle
peut aussi être tragique les psychoses
possible des chamans profiteurs ou des
révélations bouleversantes l'ayahuasca
n'est pas pour tout le monde
dans le doute même des adeptes en
conviennent il vaut mieux s'abstenir
[Musique]
c'est tout pour nous on espère que vous
avez apprécié le reportage de ce soir au
nom de toute l'équipe merci beaucoup
d'avoir été là est revenu nous la
semaine prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]